Last thing. I was listening to his
buddy guy. Ah, those is alive and well,
but he guys, and there
was the album, he's a,
I think about to turn 82
I'm going to go to Chicago,
put out a new album and just put that too.
And it's a bad ass album.
Of course it is. Oh, he rips
it the whole, he's amazing.
But that inspires me to still,
by the way,
everything about aging is about relevancy.
How are you contributing? Right?
Like George Carlin,
no one care,
the George Cardinal was doesn't matter
75 or whatever it was. That was a mentor.
He's relevant.
That's what I aspire to.
Relevancy to contribute to
mankind, to my art, to everything.
So I'll never be like,
you know,
if someone says who's that old dude and
I'm not doing anything based on what I'm
aspiring to do, that's their
issue. Right, right. You know,
because I will be to my
best ability relevant.
That's an interesting perspective
because it's really true,
but it's something that people don't
think about. You know it's like,
like rock stars in particular,
like no one looks at Mick Jagger and go,
why is that guy still doing it? Because
when you watch them do it, you're like,
oh Jesus, he's still doing it. He's
still doing it. He's like button. Yes.
Watching him live is ridiculous
by the way. He really moves.
No kidding around like
at the oldest 30 no,
he looks phenomenal.
He's ridiculous.
And he's 70 70 something still
shooting loads into hot models.
He had a baby recently. That's
my stage name by the way.
Yeah, yeah. That's my band.
How do you have that state
name? And that's my band's
name. I didn't license it,
so I'll give it back to you.
I have put my apologies.
Bruce Springsteen's another one
Springsteen's in his sixties by the way,
I saw that show. I saw that show
and I, my jaw was on the floor.
I could not believe that's Broadway shows,
Broadway show.
It was one of the greatest things I've
ever seen before. He turns to Morrow,
Jesus Christ,
and he works out,
I believe twice a day,
every day. Does he really?
He does yoga and he trains
with weights and all.
See if he could find Mick
Jagger shirtless. Uh, as ton.
Yeah. But I mean like recent, right.
Well then I would go to tools,
go to tools to the
right and then go to uh,
yeah, time. Yeah. There we go.
Say right recent.
See if he can find a recent one.
There's a lot of pictures
of him when his clothes off.
Jesus Christ make put a fucking shirt on.
But he a hot model.
A interesting man.
That's why I said to you,
there's always exceptions are far right.
What do you got there at the model?
Oh that's not Mick Jagger. You son of a
bitch. That's him at 40 with the beard.
I know that for sure. So that's
the oldest one I seen. Okay.
Well either way, the guy,
no, he's, he's really crazy.
What is movements or what's amazing?
His voice as not,
I think it's still amazing and
the way he moves. It's so fluid.
It's so beautiful. He does a lot of
yoga. I'm pretty sure Google is workout.
Mick Jagger's workout cause um,
he's incredibly disciplined apparently.
And then look up, uh, Barnaby
Jones reunion. Oh, just
out of curiosity. Common.
Look at him. Look at that right there.
Takes up yoga at 73. There you go. Oh,
is that what he did? Oh, I should.
Oh, it takes up aerial yoga,
I guess you're doing it on the ground.
Didn't work for him enough anymore.
Not Enough. And you had a ticket to a
new level. That's just ridiculous. Yeah.
Incredible. Mick Jagger at
Diet and exercise program.
Live long, long stay young.
What if he only eats peppers?